[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes I'm Katie balls The Spectators
political editor and your host for this
week's show
Neil Ferguson writes in this magazine
why he thinks Donald Trump is not just
going to win the Republican nomination
but also the presidential race he joins
me alongside Freddie Gray
there's another election coming up more
imminently that's in Turkey edgy Tamil
curin writes that It's the final
countdown for this Middle Eastern
democracy she'll be on to explain
in Westminster The Fallout from the
local elections goes on as the Tories
recover from a very bad night but Liz
truss is keeping herself busy at least
the former prime minister is off to
Taiwan will be catching up with the
spectator's political correspondent
James Hill
is on the show to talk about Russians
child Snatchers
and finally Damien Thompson will be
joining to review the music of the
coronation he'll be giving us his
verdict of what went right and the one
thing that went wrong
once again thanks to Canada wealth
management for sponsoring this week's
episode can Accord will provide you with
the expertise you need to help you build
your wealth with confidence
visit candywealth.com for more
information
now this week Donald Trump has ordered
to pay five million dollars in Damages
to a writer who claims he raped her in a
changing room almost 30 years ago
it was a civil case and he was found not
guilty of rape but was ordered to pay
for distress
so is his White House bid now over
perhaps not says the historian Neil
Ferguson he joins me now alongside
spectator Deputy editor Freddie gray to
talk about what Donald Trump 2.0 could
look like
how can Trump come back from this
the way he's come back from so many
other things uh I mean there are many
many cases coming up this is just the
early stage of of the lawfare that is
being waged against Trump uh and uh this
is uh uh an important uh moment uh in
the minds of liberal commentators
because they say well he'll never get
another woman to vote for him uh from
now until after 2024 is safely over and
I this is a misreading uh of the
situation uh we don't need to go into
the specifics of the case just assume
that there will be some legal case or
rather about Donald Trump in the news
every month from now until the election
which seems about right because there
are at least 17 cases coming up uh what
does that mean well it means he's highly
likely in fact to get the nomination for
the Republican party because no other
candidate will get any news coverage and
this is part of the Democrats strategy
they want to run against Trump and these
cases are designed simultaneously to
make Trump the nominee and to discredit
him in the eyes of various voting groups
and I just think the strategy is going
to fail and it's going to fail for one
very very simple reason there is highly
likely to be a recession between now and
November of next year and no president
since Calvin Coolidge nearly 100 years
ago has won a re-election if there's
been a recession in the two years before
that election that's the problem for the
Democrats they can do all the lawfare
they like but it's the economy stupid
remember
Freddie do you think the Democrats are
right to think because Donald Trump is
their best hope of the various potential
candidates when it comes to a race for
Joe Biden leading for them uh no I'm not
sure they are I mean the polls it's too
early to say because these poles are
very raw still but the polls suggest
that Trump has a better chance against
Biden than Ron DeSantis does who's the
sort of putative rival that everyone's
talking about I think the Democrats as
as Neil says they a lot of them think
they're playing a very very clever game
uh and this game could easily blow up in
their faces
um quite how sort of high level this
clever game goes quite how deliberate
and coordinated it is I think it's hard
to say I think you can sort of get into
the realm of conspiracy theories I think
that all of these cases are sort of
strategized
um but it's certainly true that the
Democrats want Trump they think they can
beat Trump
um but the polls suggest early on as I
said but the poll suggests that maybe
they can't yeah do you think there's
something in Donald Trump as a scandal
proof politician with Boris Johnson that
phrase was often used in the end Scandal
did come for him eventually
um is that what we're seeing here in the
sense do you think to the base so to the
base Donald Trump needs to get out and
this could look as though it's a
conspiracy against their man well of
course if bases mattered in British
politics I don't think Boris Johnson
would have been ousted because uh he
still has a lot of support at the base
and it was Tori MPS who turned against
him uh well Trump doesn't need to worry
about Republican members of Congress who
perhaps are squeamish the way Tory MPS
are he just has to get his primary
voters out uh particularly in the early
primaries and I think he has a far
better chance of doing that than Ron
DeSantis who for all his success as
governor of Florida doesn't strike me as
the kind of person who does well in New
Hampshire or at hog fairs in Iowa Trump
has this extraordinarily committed base
of people and Frank said something
important about conspiracies that we we
may not believe in a conspiracy to wage
multiple lawsuits against Donald Trump
for political reasons but many
Republicans certainly do and that
dependent and Independence exactly who
are of course extraordinarily important
in this election remember the United
States has the non-existent party to
which more people actually affiliate
than to Republican uh or Democratic
parties The Independents and and they
are not I think persuaded by what's
going on here it's also better for Trump
I think than the election was stolen in
2020 as a narrative everybody's bored of
that except Trump but the the story
they're out to get me I I'm gonna fight
the law and I'm going to win that's a
that's a more appealing story
particularly for the kind of people that
Trump has to mobilize I mean I make the
point in in the piece that there's
something kind of Brazilian about
America these days and something more
American about Brazil and Lula's return
from actual Jail uh to defeat
bolsonaro's one of the big stories of of
last year there's no chance that Trump
Goes to Jail between now and November
2024 they can throw all kinds of lawfare
at them but that's not going to happen
my sense is that all of this ultimately
helps him uh with his base secures the
nomination the key question is does it
fundamentally alienate those people who
did not vote for him in 2020 did in 2016
are they going to stay alienated or are
they going to come back to Trump I think
there's a big difference between 2020
and 2024 2020
it was a mess there had been a recession
remember my theory is you can't get
reelected if you've had a recession well
Trump proves it along with all the other
cases along with Jerry Ford Jimmy Carter
George H.W bush Trump himself lost
because they've been a recession caused
by covert at the beginning of 2020 and
by the time he got to the election the
country felt he'd screwed the pandemic
up really badly but then it turned out
in 2021 that more people died of covert
under Joe Biden than under Trump so that
case kind of fell away most people now
realized that the pandemic was
mishandled by the bureaucracy more than
it was by Trump and in any case this is
all water under the bridge the key
question in 2024 will be the economy I'm
pretty sure given that the FED has hiked
rates by more than 500 basis points that
there's almost no way to stop a
recession now it's going to come
relatively late in the year because the
economy has so much momentum the labor
Market's still hot but that's terrible
timing for the Democrats and the lesson
of history is that if you're president
and and you're clearly to blame because
this inflation that led to the fed's
tightening was all the fault of the
Biden Administration in 2021 you're
going to get blamed people are going to
say you know what these guys gave us
inflation and now a recession Donald
Trump didn't do that Donald Trump gave
us full employment with no inflation
that's the question and and in fact
Trump hinted at that in his uh much
panned uh re-election campaign
announcement uh his 2023 2024 campaign
announcement he said uh Americans don't
feel the pain yet but it's coming on the
economy and I think that's always been
part of his plan he he's always sensed
and he has quite a good Instinct for
these things that there's a big economic
pain coming and that will play in his
favor and actually it's not just
trumpets that's that's where the sort of
talk about bases confuses people it's
not just trumpets there's a lot of
people who sort of don't love Trump but
they don't hate him either and they
might vote for him and they might not
and those people sort of went against
him in 2020 and they went for him in
2016. they could easily go back towards
him in 2024. yeah and I think they're
going to be saying to themselves not
only you know how is the economy been
they'll be asking that old Ronald Reagan
question you better off today than you
were four years ago they're also going
to be looking at Biden's foreign policy
and saying gee no end in sight to this
war in Ukraine it feels like we've run
down all our stocks of of weapons and
now the Biden folks seem to want to get
into a fight over Taiwan or we didn't
have any of that with Trump as president
now just to address a really important
point that we haven't touched on if
Trump were easy to destroy politically
he would long ago be destroyed the guy
basically was involved in an attempted
Insurrection there seems more and more
evidence to support that the thesis that
he played a pretty bad role in January
6th it certainly wasn't a good look even
if if you take the most benign reading
he did something pretty close to
inciting that mob has that hurt his
chances no he's further ahead as the
front runner than almost any candidate
in recent contested primaries so I have
to say if if he can get away with
inciting an Insurrection he can get away
with having assaulted somebody in the
mid-1990s uh in a civil case that just
doesn't seem like a career ending moment
at all by Donald Trump's standards
on that Freddy what about female voters
uh do we think that that could be an
issue for Trump at the next election and
perhaps uh the case we're talking about
would have an impact there I think it
has been an issue for him in the past
Suburban moms broke against him in 2020
quite crucially uh again though I'd say
there's an assumption among Democrats
that all women will hate him that just
isn't shared by as many or as much of
the population uh as they think it is
now before we just get Freddie to run us
through some of the potential candidates
who might try and stop Trump perhaps try
and fail
um I just uh on the point there about
Ukraine and ultimately support now do
you think that if there is a republican
you know president and that is Donald
Trump we could see actually a big change
of policy in terms of America's
engagement in Ukraine well there's the
main reason I'm talking about this
people seem to be attaching too low
probability to this scenario to say that
Trump feels less enthused by Vladimir
zielinski than Joe Biden would be the
understatement of the week he has no uh
interest I think whatsoever uh in
supporting this uh War uh I think his
lack of commitment to Nato was one of
the things that was obvious in his first
term but there were Generals uh in the
administration then whose job it was to
restrain Trump and keep him uh reading
uh the talking points on the benefits of
the western Alliance those generals will
not be involved in Trump 2.0 so I think
it's not just the the commitment to
Ukraine will weaken I think it's also
that NATO itself will find its uh its
future uh in question because Trump's
old uh and repeated question about
burden sharing can be asked yet again in
the context of the war in Ukraine where
the U.S is overwhelmingly the biggest
supporter of Ukraine despite the fact
that this is a war in Eastern Europe
um I'd also mention China I mean one of
the things that's really extraordinary
about the history of the recent past is
that it was Trump who kind of work
Americans up to the China threat but in
Trump's mind it was really just an
economic threat to which you should
respond with tariffs he wanted a trade
War it morphed into a cold war rather
against his instincts and that cold war
has been continued and intensified by
the Biden Administration particularly
the issue of Taiwan uh Biden's talked
about that far more than Trump did Trump
and John Bolton's memoir likened Taiwan
to a Sharpie a small marker pen relative
to his desk China and I think it's
obvious from that particular exchange
that Trump does not think uh Taiwan is
something worth fighting for certainly
not worth risking American lives for and
this is part of what I think Americans
will remember that there were no new
Wars or Donald Trump's watch
it's not as important as the economy but
I do think it's trivial I don't think
enthusiasm for Ukraine will be sustained
it was the current thing in 2022 it
replaced black lives matter in yards all
over Northern California but ultimately
the big lesson of of history is that
American commitment to foreign
engagements even if it's an indirect
commitment in which the Americans
themselves aren't fighting that it fades
it fades because the news cycle moves on
but perhaps that's an area where Biden
hasn't actually blundered quite as much
as he could have done I mean he's been a
sort of reluctant publicly reluctant
supporter of Ukraine in some ways I mean
vocally yes but he's always been sort of
backed into the tanks the Jets he hasn't
been it's not it's not an intervention
in a sort of Iraq or Afghanistan but
with every passing month the commitment
gets larger and more expensive and it
was Biden who went to cave and appeared
side by side with zielinski stressing
that the United States would do quote
whatever it takes now that's all very
well and good right now but when the
recession comes as I think it likely
will Americans are going to start asking
the question why are we spending all
this money on a war in Eastern Europe
that really is the responsibility of the
Europeans I don't think that that issue
is particularly good for Biden and it
might get steadily worse for him as the
war drags on you talk briefly there
about
um you know Biden economy and Trump and
the economy in relation to foreign
policy and so on a big thing of course
is the inflation reduction Act
and although that's very unpopular in
Europe with European leaders and people
I think moves like that actually have
helped by perhaps in the midterms they
helped uh economic protectionism is
popular in America yes but and Biden or
Biden whether he knows it or not has
latched onto that has continued who
revived protectionism Donald Trump yeah
I mean the only the interesting thing
about the Biden Administration is that
it actually is more protectionist
because the inflation reduction Act is
actually more protectionist in practice
than Trump's tariffs were but all this
represents is the stealing of clothes I
mean what the Biden folk realized was oh
we better remain hawkish on China
because that work for Trump we can't
take the tariffs off because those work
for Trump and all of this just pays him
the ultimate compliment and imitations a
sincere form of flattery and if I'm an
American who thinks that industrial
policy Works which it doesn't but if I
think that it works well why not just
get the original why why get the
knockoff Biden version when you can have
the original Trump and partly for the
reasons you just set out in it I
wondered Freddie that if we were to get
Trump 2.0 this would be an emboldened
Trump uh one even less likely to listen
to experts advisors in the white house
when it comes to yes foreign policy but
but also a range of issues because they
would come and thinking I know exactly
what I want to do I think it would be
emboldened in a lot of ways particularly
on this sort of War on the Deep State as
he dubs it because I think there's a
feeling in Trump World that his big
mistake and I think Trump even was sort
of slightly acknowledged it that his big
mistake was he tried to work with
Washington he didn't fully go to war
with Washington and destroy all the
institutions of American government as
he should have done so I think he'd be
emboldened to do that again he would
find that it's harder to do in practice
than in rhetoric but I think the way
he's talking about the Deep State now I
mean it's very very incendiary he said
recently you know I will be your
retribution this is almost a Biblical
talk and I think that is that's going to
be if he wins with that kind of angry
message then I think you're going to see
a much Bolder Trump in 2024 if he wins
yeah No More Mr Nice Guy doesn't seem
like an appropriate phrase in case of
people trying to be nice but I I
definitely agree with you I mean and if
you talk to people who were in the Trump
Administration that the conversation is
essentially we won't be caught out next
time around we've learned the pitfalls
so I think it will be very different and
there won't be the same restraining
influences nor the concessions to
establishment and bureaucratic interests
the characterized particularly the first
couple of years and this should make the
Democrats really afraid because what
Trump was able to do in his first term
the Supreme Court could be done on a
much larger scale across all the
different agencies if they approach it
with sufficient ruthlessness and I think
that was that's exactly what they do
yeah and do you think it'd be good for
the economy yeah yeah and this is the
great thing to remember the day that
it's clear on the night that it's clear
that Trump's been re-elected heads will
be exploding on the Harvard campus and
Stanford campus the Yale campus the new
York Times officers CNN will be in
meltdown everybody will be on air in
tears predicting the end of the
Republicans all of that stuff will be
going on and the market will be rallying
because investors will know that this
will represent an improvement just as it
was an improvement when Trump got
elected I mean the Trump Administration
got no plaudits for this because the
media refused to acknowledge it but in
fact the deregulation and the tax cuts
delivered significant improvements the
labor market uh was in great shape for
the first time since 1999 real household
disposable income went up it had
flatlined since the Clinton years and
Trump delivered a nine percent increase
uh in real disposable household income
now people have got short memories in
America but they're not that short and
people aren't so suffering from Amnesia
that they've forgotten how well things
were going until the pandemics drop now
we're nearing the end of the segment
um briefly Freddie we meant is that
anyone else who potentially could stop
at least the first stage of trump 2.0 by
getting that Republican nomination I
don't think so I think Nikki Haley's not
going to go anywhere and that would be
the only other candidate that might
Pence is not going to happen DeSantis
was the only person that might have
stopped Donald Trump there was a sort of
interesting moment after the midterms uh
where a lot of the right-wing media got
behind DeSantis and there was a bit of
excitement there but the law fair works
for Trump
um in the sense that he's sucking all of
the oxygen out of the conversation
Republican politics DeSantis is fading
in the polls uh he's been wrong footed a
little bit on things like Ukraine
um and Biden's Trump is canny you know
on New Hampshire Trump's talking a lot
about social security New Hampshire is
an early primary State uh he knows that
the census is is not trusted on Social
Security and New Hampshire voters care a
lot about that so he he picks his issues
very carefully and he's a brilliantly
effective campaign China whatever you
think of Donald Trump you have to
acknowledge he is very very good at
crunching things down to very sort of
key points and hammering them very hard
DeSantis has had successful election
campaigns he's been an effective
governor in many ways but is he As Good
As Trump at the sort of really nasty
presidential campaign politics so far
the evidence is no and is your base case
ready uh the same in the sense that you
think it is is your base case for the
U.S election a Donald Trump victory
I'm going to differ with with Neil now I
think he's probably he'll probably be
right in the end but but for now I'm
going to say I think as things stand
Biden just edges Trump but I think it'll
be much closer than people think and
Neil just finally you can tell me if I'm
being too nosy
um for you and their American citizen
could you ever be tempted to vote for
Donald Trump I didn't vote for him in
2020. I just felt that things had been
disgracefully mismanaged uh but I have
to say that if you ask me to make a
choice between Joe Biden he'll be 82 and
Donald Trump in 2024. I'll find it quite
hard not to vote for Trump uh and that's
going to get me canceled back at
Stanford right now you'll go for the
spring chicken that is Donald Trump
well I mean let's face it you're as
young as uh you sound yes and there's no
doubt who sounds a lot younger and it's
not Joe Biden thank you Neil thank you
Freddie
erdogan is facing the challenge of his
political career this Sunday as turkey
goes to the polls
edu tamilkirin in this week's magazine
says that it's the final countdown for
democracy in the country she joins me
now along with Hannah Lucinda Smith
did you write for the upcoming elections
in Turkey
and you're explaining to a western
audience how we should understand the
political scene and you use an example
involving brexit and Trump can you talk
us through this
not sure I mean like we all those people
who come from complicated non-western
countries we have to simplify things
for the Western audience to have an
access to our Madness so to speak so
yeah I'm using that you know imagine 20
years of brexit pending or imagine a
trump with political genius and Islamic
aspirations
recently we had to do it for the
earthquake as well to explain the you
know
the scale of the impact we were saying
that it's one Austria or two swedens and
so on so this is what we do I mean like
we're trying to break down our
extremely complex Insanity for the
Western audiences and this was all the
only way to explain how Turkish people
feel after 20 years of erdogan I think
Hannah could you give us a summary of
the election campaigns so far
yeah so I mean it got off to a quite a
slow start
um yeah at the beginning when
campaigning started in late March
um the government said you know out of
respect for the earthquake victims we're
going to keep it located there's going
to be no music there's not really going
to be you know what you usually have in
a Turkish election campaign which is you
know election Vans driving around and
every Public Square you have you the
parties setting out their stalls and
playing music
yeah they said at the start this time
around it's going to be very low key and
it was until the end of Ramadan
um the end of April and then since then
it's really
really you know got into gear and I
think particularly since you know
erdogan and his team have realized that
they are in danger of losing that
there's a possibility that they could
lose this one
um you know kilish derolu has never
looked like a particularly hopeful
candidate in the past and I think when
he was announced
um as the presidential candidate back in
March probably the government and and
erdogan you know kind of thought oh
brilliant well would definitely beat him
and Against All Odds kalistarillo has
actually managed to kind of hold a
really diverse and quite fragile
Coalition together
um and I think you know particularly in
the past week
we've seen uh not only the campaigning
increase yeah both killister Olu and
erdogan held massive rallies in Istanbul
at the weekend they've been both touring
the country all over the place but also
we've seen a kind of escalation of the
rhetoric we've seen erdogan you know
increasing this kind of really divisive
really caustic rhetoric and you know at
the same time as promising all kinds of
things and talking about all the things
that he's done in 20 years in power
we've seen him going for LGBT
communities we've seen him going for
college over his alivism over his faith
um yeah we've seen a classic Urdu
Antarctic him talking about you know
people who give votes to the opposition
as terrorists so he's really turning to
all these kind of fault lines that he's
exploited in the past
um and have worked for him in the past
now the question is are they going to
work for him this time that that's the
key question
you know that's true I mean yeah we are
well I am wishing that it won't but then
I can see that it is working for his
Fanatics as we spoke earlier before the
program Hannah I mean like it is
incredible and it is not easy to explain
uh especially to Western audience why
there are still people who are
supporting you I don't want like there
is no tomorrow and we all know that like
you know they cannot be convinced
otherwise even if you come with the most
concrete uh you know if evidence that
proves that he's a yeah he's a fraud
and actually on on that I mean you write
in your piece about the final countdown
for turkey and can you talk us through
what is that stake here really for the
country I mean word again to win again
what does that mean
well um
to begin with I mean like this is two
decades-long rule out on and the first
term was a little bit Milder
uh less eventful let's say but then
after this he got he won the power for
the second time uh he kind of Unleashed
uh his aspiration for power holding on
to power forever
and especially after 2013 gezie uprising
um it became clear uh that there will be
suppression uh and you know those who do
not obey erdogan's regime will be
labeled as terrorists which has been the
case since last 10 years now
and then after 2016 uh the coup attempt
uh everything got really blurry the
equation has been used as an excuse by
erdogan to suppress the entire country
all his critics and I don't you know
there are thousands of people in prison
and tens of thousands have left Turkey
right after the coup because it became
clear that they will not be able to live
as first-class citizens
um and now there's the economic crisis
so
I don't is very clear through his
propaganda machine through his own
statements
that he's going to be ruling the country
as a you know political Asylum so to
speak
uh recently like I think it was
yesterday his interior Minister now A B
candidate
a very important political figure in
this uh you know campaign said that they
have been stomping on us referring to
the opposition and he said we are going
to be stomping all over them after the
election which is an open threat and if
you live in Turkey you know that this
means violence this means uh all out uh
you know oppression so you know Western
audiences do not do not like me using
this word but it is fascism and it will
be fully formed uh fascism after if I
don't wins this election
Hannah do you think that's fair I I
agree with that yeah I agree I mean I
think
you know clearly erdogan is
um he's an islamist of course
um but I think that there is far too
much focus on that part of what he is if
we really examine what's going on here
it's fascism I mean look at the kind of
um the definition everything in service
of the state the leader becomes
Inseparable from the state and
Inseparable from the nation so and then
you know that system wants to control
everything it wants to control art it
wants to control music culture
discussion media uh business everything
okay this is a definition of fascism and
this is what's happened in Turkey
um and I think you know we really can't
overstay if erdogan wins again and wins
another five years there is going to be
nothing left to democracy in this
country if we look at what he's done
since 2018
um you know after the last elections so
in 2018
those elections triggered a new
constitution constitution in which
erdogan is executive president in which
basically he the kind of the state is
almost kind of arranged around him like
the Sun King everything comes from him
you know the ministry is no longer
really have any autonomy
State institutions don't the courts are
full of his loyalists the Electoral
board is full of his loyalists the
security forces have been purged we
don't know really what's going on in
security forces and how loyal they are
to him give him another five years there
is going to be nothing left of the
democratic checks and balances in this
country even now really the only kind of
balance that is left is elections it's
his only Achilles heel is the fact that
he still has to go to The Ballot Box
because that's the way he came in and
that's the rhetoric he relies on you
know when you listen to erdogan talk
it's all about the will of the people
about democratization
Etc so he still relies on the ballot box
but pretty much there's almost nothing
else left in terms of democratic checks
and balances
and those elections are frequently
overshadowed like shadowed by the
election fraud massive election fraud
and
um world theft which has become so
natural that the opposition party is
giving you know seminars and briefings
about how they're going to protect the
votes from the world theft of the
government this is like insanity uh you
know on one side there is a man and his
propaganda machine going towards a war
as if and you know the opposition is
still trying to you know use the
Democratic means I think this is you
know this the importance of this
election goes Far Beyond turkey because
you know all those countries who have
been subjected to Rising
authoritarianism and have to learn uh
well if kalistaro if the opposition wins
turkey will be showing the entire world
that you know you can get rid of
authoritarian fascist leader through
Democratic means despite the fact that
he ruined every institution in the
country and not only the institutions to
be honest it's the moral demise of a
country
uh Hana would be very familiar with this
you know there are videos of AKP
supporters that are quite popular on
social media and they're showing uh I
don't want devotees rather saying we uh
you know we we are going to vote for
erdogan because he gave us the chance to
beat up the doctors if we do not like
them and they see this as uh like you
know their
um I don't know they see this there
their rightful response uh to an
oppressive Elite which is now you know
which Western world is not quite
familiar with uh that term so
um it's not only going to be fascism but
also it's going to be this
um
well I cannot not use strong words it's
going to be vandalism uh prevailing over
you know basic moral values of a country
and just on the Fallout from the result
I wondered do you think that whatever
the result is it will be accepted
yeah
what do you think Anna
listen erdogan has form I mean it in
2019 in the local elections in Istanbul
the opposition won by a superfine margin
um it was the first time in 25 years
that erdogan's party had not won in
Istanbul Istanbul is his home City it's
his power base it was like and he turned
it into a referendum on himself as well
so it's like a personal insult to him
and uh he leaned on the Electoral board
to overrule it
um now in the end what happened you know
imamuelu the opposition uh candidate
he's got a really really smart team
around him they really went for it in
terms of hitting the streets and doing
whatever they could and he won again
um but you know I think you know whether
you see this as like a hopeful sign or
um you know uh kind of warning depends
on whether you're an optimistic person
or not some people say well oh look you
know in the end democracy one personally
for me I think you know this shows that
he's totally willing to use the
institutions to overrule results he
doesn't like and I think you know this
is national elections this isn't just
Istanbul we're what four years on from
that he's gathered even more Powers you
know back in 2019 the Constitutional
Court was still somewhat independent
like now not at all
um and I think you know it comes down to
a numbers game I think if the opposition
can win it by a really clear margin and
I'm talking sort of 10 percent
then it would be very very difficult I
think for you know erdogan to lean on uh
on the bureaucracy non-state apparatus
as he did in 2019. on the other hand if
it's two percent three percent which is
what it's looking like at the moment I'm
sure he's going to do that I I have no
doubt
and just finally
and perhaps um you could explain it to
viewers on this if erdogan loses and
what can the country and those looking
all expect from the opposition it's a
coalition of different parties is that
right
okay I cannot be cool-headed about this
I have many friends who are going to
wear belly dancer costumes and dance in
in central Istanbul men and women uh so
it will be a big holiday a national
holiday for sure at least for half of
the country but they have been waiting
for this quite a long time so it will be
such a relief you have an expression in
Turkish
uh you know as if the ox that's sitting
on my chest has just got up I think the
feeling will be like that you know
finally we're going to breathe in terms
of real politics uh well I mean like I
think what a Brazilian social media user
uh said when volsonara lost goes for
turkey as well we know that it's going
not going to be heaven but at least we
will know that the doors of the hell
will be closed
uh and that's such a relief that is such
a that will be such a relief hopefully
I'm joined Now by James Hill political
correspondent and spectator and to catch
up on the week in British politics
so James we've had the local election
results coming in on Friday at the
king's coronation which I think
distracted I think we had to get to page
64 66 of the man on Sunday to to get to
the politics content and but politics is
now back what is the Fallout you've been
picking up well I think so far I think
it's not a question about receiving next
leadership but I do think there is a lot
of um discontent and I think that's been
partly directed at cchq there's a
meeting of the 1922 yesterday with Greg
Hans the party chairman and so I think
there is a sense perhaps it's maybe
about some policy tweaks and to do with
um Personnel in the Party Machine rather
than kind of any direct challenge to the
Prime Minister yes we're in the area
where there's lots of theories about
what went wrong for the conservatives
and given they lost over a thousand
cancer seats
um but these theories can often be quite
contradictory so there are Cemetery MPS
saying we must build more houses there's
some saying we've built too many houses
and are you picking up any coherent
complaints I would say that a lot of it
is in Conflict I think with each other
and I think the point is just it's all
very bad there's no easy really options
for the conservatives um you know they
were attacked in the north they're
attacked in the south in brexit areas I
mean one of my favorite stats from the
night was that labor did the best among
areas with the lease graduates but the
tourists worse among graduates so
basically they're getting pummeled by
every sort of demographic really and I
think the Tory party is just really kind
of sticking with the plan they have and
I think that was most noticeable on the
weekend after the results you had people
like Lucy Fraser doing the media around
you've seen that coming out giving
interviews and really they're just going
to stick on with five priorities and I
think hope within uh you know number 10
on cchq is that by doing so they're
going to be shown us delivering for the
British people rather than labor and the
Dems shouting from the sidelines yeah
and I mean what down the street you're
trying to effectively say and government
ministers is that but it was always
going to be a difficult night much of
this was due to the year before
um which is why I think you're having
fewer people say this is about Rishi cnx
leadership though you do get grumbles
and people saying well does he need to
do more does he need to show more of
himself does he need a big idea
um but one of the things I write about
in the politics column this week is
um that squeeze which is I think there
was an expectation Advance labor to have
a pretty good night I think you can see
some results that they had a decent
night now the largest party of local
government partly down to Tory failure
um but you know some key wins in those
areas you'd be looking at a general
election to turn red to suggest that
part is going into government
um but what's going to take lots of Tory
MPS by surprise was actually the success
by the liberal Democrats and some of the
smaller parties can you talk us through
that yes of course and I think you you
talk about you start off your column
this week with a fantastic Revelation
that Richie sunak is a big news is a
bonk Buster fan loves a good Jilly
Cooper and in Julie Cooper's books talks
about sort of a depiction of sort of
tory rural England and now you make the
point that those areas wouldn't be
voting conservative anymore
um I think that's the key Point really
it's the you're not really so much
necessarily pro-labor it was an
anti-tory strategy of the night stories
lost more than a thousand seats and
basically anywhere that you know the
greens stood in a sort of concentrated
area they could win seats there
authorities there was the Liberals
obviously did very well I think
beforehand they were expects to win
about 150 or so uh seats as a good night
and they want more than 400 the liberal
Democrats and so and they were also
taking it in quiet sort of high profile
seats as well places like Surrey Heath
Michael gove's constituency who took
control of Windsor and maidenhead they
also took the Eaton Ward which he wrote
about as well so I think it's about you
know the brand of the Tories which is
really
um very damaged and I think you've got
to remember of course that this was the
first election result since the end of
Boris Johnson the beginning and end of
Liz truss and uh you know so this is a
verdict on those as well and that's the
point that the government can't really
stress in public I would say but
privately they're making
um because they're worried about
reigniting sort of Tory tensions if
Regina frankly came out and said well
guys there was the whole mini budget and
they're delivering a sort of belated
kicking for that I think the Hope in
government is that they can kind of just
take back some of that they recognize
them sort of about their anger and then
move on and then try and sort of maybe
play on the tensions between the lib
Dems and the labor in terms of coalition
now the liberal Democrats have had a few
moments before but sometimes they can be
false Dawns yes uh if we think about
2019 then the lib Dems did fantastically
well in the European elections
um and then it came to that general
election which the liberal Democrats
helped usher in they thought it was a
good idea and it was
uh overall I think they lost one seat as
a net total
um but of the seats they lost one was
Joe Swinson the leaders and so it is
always trickier
um for them to replicate what happens at
a local elections at a general election
and that can be a regular problem for
smaller parties but often labor can do
better from local to General and what do
you think we could be looking at in
terms of where the liberal Democrats you
know how much of this lib Dem come back
you know how big is it going to be yeah
I don't think it's going to be you know
seismic necessarily but they're starting
from quite a low base so you'd expect
them to make you know sort of
double-digit games I'd say in the next
election in places obvious places
includes of Cheltenham you know the seat
of the new Justice secrets for a
majority of less than a thousand I think
that's almost certain to go liberal
Democrat next time
um other places include Isha uh Moulton
which is a Dominic Rob seat so it's kind
of places where I think you know there's
a sort of
um you know they were traditionally you
know sort of remaining notorious
basically so wealthy prosperous in the
south of England so they can expect to
make gains of I'd say around you know at
this age size of 20 or so
now two other things happening this week
let's first start with the route over EU
retained law and now this is uh
ultimately a
a troubled bill I think we could say in
the sense successive ministers with that
brief have delayed or you know dealt
with some of the issues about this plan
to repeal all the EU laws with the
sunset Clause coming badanoc the new
business secretary has made an
announcement a written ministerial
statement
um though she has had to speak since I
believe
um so what she is ultimately said that
this isn't going to happen in the way
that many brexiteers had hoped can you
talk us through it yes of course and I
think it was an issue that sort of
dominated the brexit the Boris Johnson
used was what kind of brexit wins
tangible games we're going to see and
then in the last year's summer
Leadership race we saw um Liz truss and
where she sooner tried to campaign on
the issue of making the most out of
brexit those wins famously which is not
released a video of him shredding EU law
and a shredder but actually if you look
at the wording of that announcement and
the press release around it it was
actually they're going to review a lot
of these laws rather than rip them all
up in one sort of big big bill so I
think this has been actually the
government kindly trying to escape walk
back and actually try and be realistic
about the number of regulations they can
change obviously a lot of brexiters
aren't particularly happy painting sums
yes I think it's about 400 or so rather
than but more than the 4 000 that were
part of uh rolled over from when we left
the EU and so this obviously caused a
lot of tensions I mean I think people
are already on the right to the party
were a little bit irritated by what
machine actually doing on certain areas
like tax and that kind of you know it
sort of spills over into other areas on
brexit as well and I do think it's
interesting that Kenny Bannock is doing
this at a time when she's seen by many
as a kind of future Contender for the
leadership of the party this next year
or so will be really interesting in
whether she can kind of deliver enough
meat to her kind of her base of brexite
as I would say and be seen as a
competent and effective Minister she's
talking today in the telegraph about the
Whitehall blob Etc White Machine the
challenge fair is whether she can kind
of get to grips with that and deliver on
it so I think it's an interesting
question which is how many brexiteers in
Parliament at least are really exercised
on EU retained law because you have a
chief whip meeting last night with
around 20 MPS the whips at the moment
don't seem to think when this
legislation returns and I I think you
know the jury is still there but it
might not be this huge rebellion and
instead you could have a situation a
little bit similar to The Windsor
framework where there's lots of you know
briefings multiple press conferences
from the remaining members of the
European research group but then it
isn't quite the crunch moment perhaps it
would have been you know if you think
about Breck's attentions uh in the 2017
to 2019 period yes I quite agree and I
do think there's a danger of perhaps
conflating actual numbers in Parliament
with the kind of brexit sympathetic
media landscape as a whole and I do
think one thing you can definitely say
about this Rishi sunek number 10
operation is it's much better at
parliamentary management so I think
they're doing a lot more time kind of
soothing attentions and basically just
hoping to try and keep the peace which
is probably their best bet going into
next year's election as otherwise voters
hate divided parties so I think that a
lot of these routes will be conducted in
private rather than perhaps then on the
floor of the House of coins as they did
under Liz truss and on the subject of
Liz truss finally she's going on a trip
yeah tell us more James which is going
to Taiwan and uh going to be speaking
there next week and this is something
she you know would say she feels
strongly about but it's obviously caused
a bit of tensions within her own party
Alicia currency this morning has
criticized her for supposed Instagram
diplomacy by going to Taiwan and
actually accounts did also go to Taiwan
didn't she yes I believe so and yes um
so in terms of you know there's a split
there on the Tory cynoskeptic ranks I'd
say and as I say the point is that under
Boris Johnson there were regular
rebellions on China things like the
genocide Amendment or things like Huawei
China related issues um the the Skeptics
had a difficult year or so I'd say
partly because of the association with
what happened with Liz truss and which
is not coming in to replace her but I
also think is that because the
Parliamentary management is a lot better
it means that on rebellions it's
difficult to build a head of steam and
unite around an issue and I think the
kind of tensions between
um you know Alicia Canada's Trust we've
seen play out is perhaps indicative of
that yeah and it does feel as though the
China Rebels as she is saying look at
things like that
look at things like the procurement bill
which are coming back to the house and
that's where actually they think there's
a way to tangibly affect the
government's China policy and as opposed
to uh well uh Samuel Kearns is called
Instagram diplomacy yes what you're
saying anyway thank you James for
joining spectator TV today
Lana morinets writes on this magazines
about Russia's child snatchers she joins
me now
in this week's magazine you write about
Ukraine's stolen children do you know
how many children are roughly missing
and since the invasion began right now
we know about 20 000 of Ukrainian kids
being deported to Russia and this number
was confirmed by Ukrainian National
Police because their parents and
relatives of those kids were going to
police and saying hi my kids is missing
and the kid is in Russia but the U.S
department and Ukraine's allies say that
this number is much higher we can talk
about 200 000 kids being deported to
Russia
and how does it happen
um ultimately what is the process for a
child being taken are there common
methods
is there are various ways but the most
common is when parents who live in
occupied territories are told that the
kid must go to the Russian Camp to have
a vacation some rest from their
hostilities and if parents say no they
are threatened to be deprived of their
parental rights so they don't have a
choice
and uh usually a Russian forces promised
to take a kid for one two weeks and then
bring it back but they end up staying in
Russia or occupied territories for
months till they are rescued but in most
of the cases they just stay there and
also there is a process called field
trash filtration when families try to
leave the occupied territories and
Russian forces decide who can lead and
who not so sometimes in that moment they
separate their mother and the kid
and how are some parents going about
trying to be reunited with their lost
children this is a very complicated
thing to do because first they need
their foreign passports to travel abroad
and the charity side of Ukraine helps
them to do that and to go they put them
in the bus and send them to Russia but
the problem is that mostly parents don't
know where their kids are because
Russians are hiding their location or if
their location leaks they just move them
from one cap to another to the
orphanages or to the Foster families so
only those kids who are all there they
have a phone or they know the number
they can ask someone to call their
parents and they say hi Mom I'm here
could you please pick me up and only in
that case it is possible that parents
can go and take them but there is also a
problem that Russia allows to do that
within six months since the it was
abducted so after six months they
started the process of adoption
so the time is very limited
now we're about to see an interview
conducted can you just uh talk us
through what we're about to watch yes I
spoke to the uh 16 years old boy and his
mother he was taken from her son region
to the Russian camp in occupied Crimea
and instead of two weeks two weeks he
spent there six months till he was
rescued and he talked about all the
things that he witnessed there thank you
sir Donna we'll watch that now foreign
[Music]
universe
foreign
magazine
toilet
is
foreign
canal
device
thank you
sacrifices
and finally Damian Thompson reviews The
Music of the coronation he says there is
much to be happy about and one problem
he joins me now
Damien you write in this week's magazine
about the music King Charles coronation
you say it was a Triumph how oh it was
the English call Tradition at its best
only the English have got a world-class
choral tradition anywhere in the world
for a complicated historical reasons but
you had several fabulous choirs and a
wonderful Orchestra world-class
conductors and some magnificent music
I'm not convinced by all of the new
commissions but you cannot beat I was
glad and zadok the priest both of which
were actually written for English
coronation you say that what makes the
perfect coronation song is knowing how
to raise the temperature by subverting
expectations
um can you tell us a little bit more
about that
yeah I was pleased with that pretentious
little observation but it's true
why does your spine tingle with I was
glad
even if you don't know anything about
Harmony and I don't know that much but
you take in subconsciously that the glad
chord Mass Accord Is Not the One You're
Expecting it's not the one that the
converter has led you to expect because
he begins in B flat and then suddenly
there's this G major chord which is
quite a remote called glad I was doing
that and it's just not the call You're
Expecting and it's thrilling handle does
something similar
in zadok the priest in other words
he subverts our expectations so there's
always
but it's the chords he moves through
aren't the ones you're expecting so he
goes into the minor and he goes on a
little sort of Journey
um into into different keys and then
works his way back to the tonic and it's
the Journey Back to the tonic that's
building expectations and then he hits
the tonic with
zadok and it's just
an explosion of sound and it it doesn't
matter that you know it's coming because
you will once you know you it's not kind
of it's not a surprise after you've
heard it once but you know that the
thrill is coming which Amounts is the
same sort of thing now it wasn't as long
a ceremony as the Queens but it was
still lengthy and so Damien I wondered
how did how do they go about getting the
balance right and do you think they
struck were there any moments where it
lacked or sagged a bit for you I think
there was one misfire
and that was Debbie Wiseman was she
called wrote two alleluias she's a film
composer and they're both pretty good
the first one was really lovely there's
a second one was some of our Gospel
Choir problem was it wasn't gospel music
um not remotely it was in quite sort of
shapely Anglican harmonies and it was
Joy it was a joyful halleluia but it did
not
match the movements of The Quiet it just
wasn't gospel music and there was and
they were you know singing and moving as
if it was gospel music and it wasn't so
I thought that was a bit embarrassing
but just a very very minor thing the
Lloyd Webber not the most memorable
piece I've ever heard but then that's
not Lloyd Webber for you he's not an ear
worm composer and he's great at creating
a theatrical atmosphere he's he's a very
good technical converter his father was
a composer of anchor and social music
but the king apparently wanted something
people would go out humming
said diplomatically on Sky TV oh well um
perhaps I'll need to hear it again I'm
not sure they'll get the charm well
girls I think people went out humming I
suspect was they look the priest because
it's so marvelous at least I'm still
hunting it now okay thank you very much
for joining us today Damien
that's it for this week
once again thanks to can Accord Unity
wealth management for sponsoring this
week's episode canacord will provide you
with the expertise you need to help you
build your wealth with confidence
visit can do wealth.com for more
information
[Music]